yeah we have uh kunai mahmud
zara from team pogar
uh i think she's uh
um
yeah pretty pretty decent i am
from
from azerbaijan uh
and uh i think the first board of
azerbaijan's women women's team and i
think she
she is still a junior or
close to it and
as far as i know a pretty aggressive
player
let's play an old
banter blitz favorite of mine the the
old
scandinavian
and yeah
don't take pay too much attention to the
ratings in general
a lot of them are
provisional and they don't make any
it could make any sense
yeah h3 i guess is a reasonable move i
see i've seen some people play that
guess i should go bishop f5 to develop
and knight d7
and
i'm not sure i like castling king side
there it feels a little bit too soft
so now i get easy development and then
yeah she's probably slightly better but
i have what i wanted from the opening
which is
a very solid and
playable position
guess i'll go rookie
e8 and then rook d8 later on maybe
but in general
she has a slight space advantage but
i don't think she can use it for for
much meanwhile my position is very solid
bishop f4 i can go queen b4 so i'm not
really worried about
my queen here
i also don't really think
any
knight f7 and g4 is gonna work
um
obviously i could be eating eating my
words later
you always have to prepare for that
possibility i think i'll trade for now
don't love the bishop coming to e5 but i
think it's safe
next mayor for the king
um
okay queen f5
maybe
rook d7 next move to make
room for the
queen on d8
like a little mini plan here then bishop
d6 challenging
challenge challenging the bishop
seems reasonable
also potentially rook d8
and again i don't think she has any
tactics here
with b6
so i think she's uh
um there are maybe there are some
tactics here like
queen d8 d5
and
95 95 cd5
bishop a4
with uh winning the exchange
so
even in apparently very dry positions
there are sometimes tactics
now i will go bishop g6 and i think
that's
in general
not undesirable and their ideas of
bishop h5 potentially forcing
potentially forcing g4
obviously now
um
now that she's gone rook d
two that's not an issue anymore
okay let's go queen da to continue with
the
with the plan that bishop d6
if bishop
d's f6 i'm pretty happy to trade them
play an ending
guess oh this is a tricky move order
uh
thing is i would love to go bishop d3
and then take an e5
but bishop b5
uh de5 bishop d3 i guess
ef6 is an issue
and if bishop d3 she can take on f6
and force an equal ending
okay so she did play this well okay she
took immediately so i could have spared
myself
that whole
that whole speech
okay let's simplify the game
or she doesn't even trade
okay it's interesting i'm not sure it's
good i think my position is very solid
here and the knight on d6 and itself
is uh
not gonna not gonna do any damage
i have to play faster
okay let's see if let's bring the knight
to b5
knight c4 comes logical
and in c5 okay she trades now
fe3 yeah fe3 is probably good she's
playing this well
she's playing this really well
b6 okay time is becoming a serious issue
here as well
c5
let's try and bring the knight around
okay let's instead go for f6
b4 i'll take
this looks reasonable bringing the
knight to d4 but
obviously time is
more than a serious issue at this point
okay
i'll have to hustle her
not taking a draw even though i'm
low on time with uh no advantage
can i to b4
let's go take take take take the rook
she's collapsing i'm collapsing a bit as
well
okay let's go let's go
let's go
yeah there we have checkmates
okay
okay
oh well
oh well
oh well
i wasn't very good i was just
a little more hustle as i talked about
earlier
the scramble was decent
not penguin level but
very decent but
before that she played she played a
great game and she was serious better
and
deserved more than
an
unceremonious
flag
to be fair